so let's get to yesterday's testimony. Do
not allow yourselves to be tricked by Donald
Trump writing in huge Sharpie, no quid pro
quo. We'll get to that Sharpie later. Yesterday's
testimony from Gordon Sunland confirmed the
quid pro quo bribery, extortion, Ukraine deal
working through Rudy Giuliani on the behalf
of Donald Trump. When asked, EU ambassador
Gordon Sunderland said in the most explosive
testimony thus far, yes, there was a quid
pro quo, uh, involving politically motivated
smear investigations into, uh, Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden getting, uh, Ukraine. A meeting
with Trump was part of it. Military aid was
thrown in there, but even more importantly,
maybe Sunland has thrown everyone under the
bus saying, Mike, Palm, PEO knew what was
going on. Rudy Giuliani was central to what
was going on. Sunland said everyone was in
the loop. Mike Pence knew Mick Mulvaney knew.
Sunland said they were all in on it. Let's
look at two key clips starting with this one.
I don't intend to repeat my prior opening
statement or attempt to summarize 10 hours
of previous deposition testimony. However,
a few critical points have been obscured by
noise over the last few days and weeks. And
I'm worried that the bigger picture is being
ignored. So let me make a few key points.
First, secretary Perry, ambassador Volker
and I worked with mr Rudy Giuliani on Ukraine
matters at the express direction of the president
of the United States. We did not want to work
with mr Giuliani. Simply put, we were playing
the hand we were dealt. We all understood
that if we refuse to work with mr Giuliani,
we would lose a very important opportunity
to cement relations between the United States
and Ukraine. So we followed the president's
orders.
Rudy Giuliani was imposed on them by Donald
Trump and the key line, of course, the quid
pro quo.
I know that members of this committee frequently
frame these complicated issues in the form
of a simple question. Was there a quid pro
quo? As I testified previously with regard
to the requested white house call and the
white house meeting, the answer is yes. Mr
Giuliani conveyed to secretary Perry, ambassador
Volker and others that president Trump wanted
a public statement from president Selenski
committing to investigations of barista and
the 2016 election.
Sunderland admits he worked on this for Trump.
Rudy told him let's pressure Ukraine to announce
these investigations. Remember that Donald
Trump first called song Linda, really good
man. When it looked like sun Lind was going
to be useful to Trump, but now Trump is distancing
saying, this is not a man. I know. Well, it's
funny. I tweeted, uh, let me see if I can
even pull it up because I, I had a moment
where I sort of summed it up in a way I thought
it was interesting. Sunland was hired by Trump
who hires the best people, which is why Trump
said we could believe Sunland at first. But
then when it became clear, Sundland was saying
things damaging to Trump. This is why we elected
Trump to get people like Sunland out of government
who Trump barely knows how quickly the story
changes as we have all very, very quickly
learned with Donald Trump.
Now, another general area of concern here,
which hasn't been discussed much since the
songline testimony yesterday, is that the
degree to which Rudy Giuliani as an unelected
private person is doing the bidding of the
president internationally, including even
directing American ambassadors about what
to do is truly disgusting and concerning in
and of itself. Rudy is representing Trump's
wants and needs and desires and needs. Around
the world and he's no one, I mean, in the
end, he's Trump's TV lawyer. He is a lawyer
in the sense that many people with law degrees
in the U S become effectively lobbyists and
peddlers of political influence. And Rudy
is traveling around the world telling them
ambassadors what to do, which country to pressure,
who to lean on, what the deliverables are
that are expected. And it is of course, something
that Republicans will do everything possible
not to discuss. Instead focusing on attacking
Gordon Sunderland's credibility and whether
they succeed at doing that depends on what
you are open to believing.
Now, hilariously, at one point, Scott Perry,
who's a Republican, criticized Sunland for
listening to what Rudy said over what Donald
Trump said, which is hilarious because Rudy
was there for Donald Trump, the Republicans,
some realizing, you know, this unelected guide,
Rudy Giuliani traveling around, having meetings
with people. He's not Senate confirmed. He's
really directing people at a very high level
to do this, that, or the other thing for Donald
Trump. That doesn't look good. They realize
that it doesn't look good. And Perry said,
well, you're in the wrong. Gordon song, Lin,
because you were listening to Rudy instead
of the president. Well, the whole point is,
Rudy was there to communicate the desires
of the president in a way that least at least
put like, you know, half, half a layer of
separation, even though it's obvious why Rudy
was there, it was one of the most, uh, flacid
and transparent attempts to try to criticize
Sunland when really the, here's the real question
about sunlit.
Okay. Uh, the question about Sundland is,
is he a witness here or is he a co-conspirator?
Like in listening to the testimony yesterday,
the biggest question Mark is not did Trump
do it? Did Trump and Giuliani and all of them
know about it? The real question is, should
we be seeing Sunland as someone who is merely
reporting what he saw? Or is he actually a
co-conspirator because he admits, Oh no, I
did this stuff Rudy told me to do. I did this
stuff that Trump's white house had people
all over the world disseminating as what it
was that needs to happen. So that's really
the question. I came away with Sunland as
a witness or Sunland as a co-conspirator.
Let me know what you think. Um, Republicans,
uh, of course wanted to act like Sunderland's
testimony wasn't damaging, but at one point
it was amazing. The camera flashed to Devin
Nunez, the ranking member on the house Intel
committee.
He looked white, he looked sick to his stomach.
He looked like he had had some bad clams and
was about to have to excuse himself as Gordon
Sandlands testimony wrapped up. Find that
moment. Uh, we will take a quick break, much
more to discuss. Remember that on black Friday
we will be emailing everybody on our mailing
list with a just extraordinary membership
special. If you've been thinking about becoming
a supporter of the David Pakman show, which
I would encourage you to do, quite frankly,
I'm biased, but I would encourage you to do
it. Um, get on our mailing list that David
pakman.com and then on black Friday you will
get an email
with a super, super secret one day use code
to sign up for membership at a, an obscenely
discounted price. Let me just put it that
way. Quick break back
after this,